hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be addressing all of the
rumors surrounding perspective Harry
Potter TV shows and future Harry Potter
films I've been seeing a lot of
commotion online and in my own comment
section lately discussing the future of
the Harry Potter franchise and what may
be next most likely these conversations
have been reignited by the success of
the newly released Harry Potter game are
called Legacy fans are now wanting
additional Harry Potter content more
than ever which puts franchise owner
Warner Bros in a good position Harry
Potter is arguably in the best state
that we've seen since the original films
came out with previous Harry Potter game
and film releases Fantastic Beasts
succumbing to the incorrigible scrutiny
of devote Harry Potter fans across the
globe finally things seem good nature is
healing and with this recent success
I've been bombarded with article after
article online line boasting about the
next big film and or TV show that's
going to fit into the franchise but is
this genuine news or is this just the
same old title being recycled for the
nth time is there actually something on
the horizon let's take a look the first
title we're going to look at is Hogwarts
Legacy show in the works well that and
50 other variations of this same title
this headline has been making its way
all around the internet in the last
couple of weeks and what I want to
uncover is whether or not this headline
is legitimate what does it mean well
this headline suggests there's going to
be a potential TV series based around
Hogwarts Legacy which takes place in the
1800s and features a plethora of new
characters this show would allow Warner
Bros to explore a previously Uncharted
era of the magical world this show would
also operate with the added benefit that
it's not too closely tied to existing
characters and story lines in the Harry
Potter and fantastic Beast film
franchises this will allow them to tell
their own story and deep dive into the
Wizarding world's Rich history
but is it actually going to happen well
the truth is that it's not confirmed
it's a wonderful idea and it's an easy
headline to run but in actuality I
expect that these proven sources listed
inside of these same articles are simply
illegitimate Warner Bros have yet to
make any announcements on this topic
whatsoever and given that the game is
still rolling out on various consoles I
don't expect that we'll receive an
update on this anytime soon with that
said however I do expect the immense
success of the game to spark something
just not immediately I suppose this is a
possibility but as far as the rumors are
concerned this is not something that's
currently in motion before the time
being when it comes to a Hogwarts Legacy
TV series well I wouldn't hold your
breath which brings us to our next hot
ticket item the alleged cursed Child
movie with reprisals from some of the
original Harry Potter actors I've seen
this headline everywhere what Warner
Bros are currently looking at how to
bring the cursed child to the big screen
a source reported to the Sun at the
moment it is in very formative stages
and they are discussing the next steps
to move it forward the cursed child play
was written collaboratively by JK
Rowling Jack Thorne and John Tiffany it
premiered in London in 2016 and went on
to become a huge success mainly among
non-potter heads I suspect winning all
sorts of awards but as far as Story Goes
The Cursed child is one of the least
respected pieces of content tied to the
Harry Potter franchise with some fans
outright denying its existence the
cursed child takes place 19 years after
the events of the Deathly Hallows and
follows Harry Potter's son Albert
Severus Potter as he navigates through
Hogwarts and deals with the legacy of
his father's past but bearing in mind
all of the Canon blunders and the fact
that it wasn't written exclusively by
Rolling it's certainly hard to accept so
what's the likelihood that this play
will be adapted into film from where I'm
sitting it all seems rather unlikely
this is just another one of those
headlines that's been recycled over and
over again to the point that it no
longer Bears any meaning in my view the
cursed child is potentially Warner Bros
least valuable pieces of Ip inside of
the Wizarding World so to adapt this
play into a film rather than Focus their
efforts elsewhere would be ludicrous the
next component to this story is that all
three main actors from the original
films Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson
Rupert Grint would all come back and
work on this project together
the dream would be to have major Stars
returning including Daniel Radcliffe but
that is still incredibly far off A
source told the sun everyone who works
within the Harry Potter World wants
Daniel to be back but first they have to
iron out the plan for how many films it
will be a reworked script and budgets
but I think it's just that a dream to
meet the inclusion of this information
just makes the possibility of this film
even more unlikely in the 20th
anniversary special Harry Potter
returned to Hogwarts some of the actors
discussed returning to the franchise 20
years from now but that was more in
response to the idea of another reunion
so are there any confirmed pieces of
information pointing to this film being
made absolutely not and do I want this
one to happen not really so where does
that leave us is anything going to
happen it seems like over the last
couple of years we've been teased
incessantly by Warner Bros execs and
media Outlets alike about the
possibility for a Harry Potter reboot
whether in the form of a TV show or
movie in a statement a few months back
CEO David zaroslav emphasized the
importance and significance of the Harry
Potter IP belonging to them we're going
to focus on franchises he said what are
the movies that have brands that are
understood and loved everywhere in the
world we haven't done a Harry Potter in
15 years and it wasn't long before
zazlov's statement that Warner media's
former CEO of Jason collar also
discussed Harry Potter's potential as
well as his intentions for creating a
Harry Potter TV show there's this little
thing called Harry Potter which is one
of the most beloved franchises and we're
incredibly thankful to be able to
partner with JK Rowling and so I would
argue there's a lot of fun and potential
there as well killar said but these
statements while exciting are also
always famously vague carefully avoiding
the specifics of what may happen and
when why not a Marauders show why not to
show on the founders of Hogwarts why not
a show on Voldemort's Origins as of
right now there are certainly lots of
rumors circulating about potential Harry
Potter TV shows and movies but what's
important to remember is that nothing
has been confirmed certainly don't
believe the first headline you see and
if it seems too good to be true it
probably is however given the recent
successes of the franchise largely due
to Hogwarts Legacy it's likely that the
surge in popularity and profitability
will push franchise owners to produce
more Harry Potter content in the near
future perhaps the Hogwarts Legacy show
is the next most likely option I'll also
say this Hogwarts Legacy has seriously
broken the Harry Potter lull for me so
although I'd like a TV show or film to
follow the game up I'm fine to wait for
a little while and that's it for this
video if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel what movie TV show would you
want to see did you fall victim to these
rumors leave a comment down below until
now next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live